jury selection is set to begin today in
a murder trial of Imam in Idaho accused
of killing her two youngest kids and her
husband's ex-wife Lori valadebell could
face life in prison if convicted she has
pleaded not guilty her children Joshua
J.J valo and Ty Lee Ryan were last seen
alive more than three years ago in their
disappearance gained national attention
Jonathan bigliotti is following this
complicated and bizarre case
the last time Lori valadebell was seen
in court she chose to remain silent as
the judge entered a plea on her behalf
we'll enter a not guilty plea as it
relates to all of the counts alleged
today's trial in Idaho is focused on
three killings her children Tyler Ryan
and Joshua J.J valo and her husband's
previous Wife Tammy daybell Chad where
are Lori's kids suspicions started
swirling around dabel and her husband
Chad and author of religious doomsday
novels after her children seemingly
disappeared in late 2019 shortly after
Tammy dabell died under mysterious
circumstances in June of 2020 the
children's bodies were found buried on
Chad dabel's Idaho property prosecutors
say the couple killed all three fueled
by their end of times beliefs to steal
Social Security funds and insurance
money Chad dabel will be tried
separately he has pled not guilty I
think that her men's team absolutely
will say that she really wasn't the
driving force behind any of her actions
and that she really was not the one who
was guilty of these crimes
[Music]
for years the media followed the day
Bells complicated and convoluted history
becoming the subject of a Netflix
docu-series despite the national and
Global interests in the trial the judge
has barred cameras from the courtroom
this is the way to control the
proceedings to make sure that the
prosecution and the defense are making
their case to the jurors and not to a
much larger audience who actually won't
vote on guilt or innocence Lori
valadevel also faces conspiracy charges
in Arizona connected to the 2019
shooting death of her previous Husband
by her brother who died shortly
thereafter
for CBS mornings I'm Jonathan Vigliotti